the jurogan experience hey rob if you're
listening i want to go to your house i
do have my passport in my he's in jail
oh i'll still go to your house i mean
the guy's an artist my favorite line in
that song is he goes [ __ ] i wish you
would burn my [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i wish you would burn my [ __ ]
clothes it's just real conversation with
somebody just doesn't so funny to get
caught cheating and like think you have
a good point were the other guys were
there other guys right did you say that
back yeah tell me this gotcha how the
[ __ ] you know i was with them other
girls
it's amazing i might start sing fighting
with my girlfriend and she's like yeah
she's like stop playing xbox i'm like
[ __ ]
i like playing xbox what's amazing is
how many years he got away with doing
what he was doing because all this real
talk was after the videotape got
released the chappelle sketch wasn't
yeah
yeah that one was a known thing that
he'd like to piss on young chicks and
this was right this was 2007. it was
funny never got edited out of the movie
it was funny
edit what out of him he never got edited
out of any movies because he's in space
yeah that was a huge thing yeah crazy
now he's in jail
i think they're posting videos of him in
jail
all the other dudes are like hell yeah
this is awesome yeah i mean cause he was
doing sets in jail he's not he was
another yeah
he's appealing and asking to be
something
well
[Music]
what's going on he they tried to delay
the sentencing just yesterday and that
got denied so it's uh may 4th and he
faces ten
we should go wait wait what's he in
trouble for tricking [ __ ]
pretty much no he's in the trouble
there's underage [ __ ] there's a lot oh
yeah there's many things just like
imprisonment i hope he sings sing
defenses
oh he was getting girls he was illegally
he would
i mean he would just maybe they must be
minors but i think he was getting girls
from like ohio or wherever and bringing
them the translation of any woman or
girl across straight lines for any
immoral purpose oh no we're all in
trouble oh yeah right what's immoral
right that's the because sodomy is like
isn't like that's
oral sex is illegal in some states
that's true so if you a girl comes
across a state line to visit you and
blow you that's always trying to tell
federal charges of child pornography and
obstruction of just separate oh that's
separate i'm actually with the people
that deny this dude
free free kills
he's innocent dude look at him find the
video
find the video of him singing in jail
go to reddit what yeah he's in jail
singing for the for the fellas i thought
that was a joke no i i've i've seen a
video of him singing in jail you think
that it's [ __ ] good prison
r kelly
[Applause]
there is something that i must confess
dude he's so good
he's basically saying don't rape me guys
please
i'll sing for you i'll play this please
please whatever you want is it more my
body is telling me yes that's he's
talking about gay sex in jail there was
a video going around i sent us a girl
last night because it's like his style
uh those that's gonna get the boys fired
up if i heard that song in there oh yeah
give you hope yeah i'd like to have sex
with that guy yeah finished that song go
now go out there and you go rape
go get those white guys on in here on
dui this video for christ's first night
my mind is telling me no my body's
telling that was one of his big
see if there's any other videos of him
in jail
who's this guy
who's got a
youtube channel
in jail
or something caught singing to a girl on
tick-tock from jail wow
try that it's an hour and 15-minute
videos
that's a lot longer today
don't you think i got enough [ __ ] on
my mind
real talk to ask you something can you
sing a song for me
which one love letter
did you get my call
[Music]
of an angel
[Music]
when your dad goes to the same prison as
our kelly
[Music]
thank you
that's adorable
same prisoners r kelly that is wild